I have a special guest with us today we
showed her video last week I don't
remember which day they all kind of get
away from me maybe she'll tell us what
day she posts I guess I could look it up
I I need I need to play this video
um because she is sounding the alarm and
she does such a great job because she
pays attention
um to these what I called before the
local politics
um she does so well and she's showing
you uh through her social media channel
how this isn't local right they're using
local politicians and local platforms
and local legislators to push their
National agenda and their National
narrative is what they're doing
um so if you call that local I guess
it's that local but it's not it's a
national narrative National messaging I
want to this is the first time she's
appeared on our show Jess Piper we've
tried to have her before but we just
never could connect but I appreciate you
uh coming and talking to us Jess how are
you I'm doing well how are you doing oh
I I'm I'm I'm fired up this morning as
always can you tell
yeah I feel the same I wake up every
morning ready to start punching yeah I
mean we we should again
um I believe that National narrative and
National messaging is one of the weapons
that we use to drive uh people to the
ballot uh and use and use their right to
vote uh to save our democracy that's I
believe how we use our democracy to save
it as they're trying to use our
democracy to destroy it and that's the
front you've been working on you've been
watching them paying attention to how
they're using democracy to really tear
it apart and tear apart the fabric of
the of the liberal democracy that we
have built in this country
um to have freedoms and rights for all
people even children so tell us because
I played a video last week and I'll
replay it here too
um you were sounding the alarm and you
actually said Sound the Alarm friends on
this video about some laws that are
being passed in Arkansas and Iowa and
all kinds of red state legislators where
Republicans have control tell us about
what what what is the the voucher system
what is it to you and what does it mean
about how they're actually trying to
roll back like child labor laws
so a voucher is uh taxpayer money given
been to a private or religious school
and these vouchers go all the way back
to the 1950s with Milton Friedman and it
was a reaction to the desegregation of
schools you know Brown V board so they
decided to create things that they
actually called desegregation academies
and they gave students tax paid funds to
go to these academies
um we had them for several years parents
in general though like their public
schools and don't want this to happen so
every time there's a big push for it
parents in general push back and say we
don't want this we like our our schools
just fund them so in the 1970s we had
you know Jerry Falwell and the Moral
Majority and they were like okay we've
got to get the evangelicals on board to
elect Ronald Reagan against a Sunday
school teacher right against Jimmy
Carter and they did that with two things
abortion and school vouchers so it's
again they couldn't say the racist part
out loud anymore but they still use
School vouchers because is the ultimate
goal is you know that desegregation and
now let's come back again and we saw a
big push with Betsy DeVos her entire
premise was to dismantle public schools
which is why they put her in charge of
of the Department of Education and now
we're seeing it in red States
um and the the biggest problem like in
Missouri where 49th in Educational
Funding 50th and teacher pay we just had
a round of some pretty bad scores you
know Statewide and our Republican super
majority who has been in charge for 20
years said say see here look these
schools suck they're failing look look
and you're like you jerks you have
defunded them for 20 years for the
reason why they suck right you did this
and by the way they don't like our
schools do really well even without the
funding they've done everything to to
try to make them fail and they're still
going well and I want to point out
because that that's a good because I
have um children in Missouri public
schools and the one reason why they do
so well is because the communities
that the the actual local politics of it
the communities step up with ptas ptos
with big fundraisers it is always the
the ability of a school to survive
um rural schools especially because they
continue to have to do fundraisers
because these Republicans that they
elect in these districts where they're
having to have all the because the
parents oh my God another fundraiser
well the reason why you have to continue
to have fundraisers is because you keep
electing the people who are defunding
your schools and and again we've talked
about it before this um this Association
because a lot of rural people do vote on
Association my grandpappy voted for
Republican you know you've ran into this
you you ran for these races but tell us
tell us the um what does this have to do
with though this voucher system how how
is how are the Republicans trying to
take advantage of the dereliction of
Duty that they've had to their out to
their constituents on education how are
they using it now to transform uh labor
laws appears to be their their their
position of what you call segregation
yeah it's absolutely and
with your own eyes you would
you would we are all under the
oppression that we always thought kids
should go to school K through 12 like
because that's I mean I'm 47 years old
that's what I've always known but
there's always been an attempt to say if
you can't pay for your kids education
they don't get an education that's the
libertarian you know Utopia and also
that children should work I mean
um and so that they think that some kids
don't need to go to school past eighth
grade but you're seeing this in Arkansas
Iowa like you said uh Wisconsin Michigan
even
um where but especially like places like
Arkansas Sarah Huckabee Sanders signed
the voucher Bill the same day she signed
a bill rolling back child labor and that
should send chills down your spine she's
made it to where people folks can hire
children and not have to report their
age to the Department of Labor
um oh surely uh Piper surely businesses
won't take advantage of that no never
surely surely they want surely for
profit corporations that are really all
in for money only in greed surely they
will they will be good stewards in this
in this effort I'm sure yes we know we
know how
operations are for the regular people so
um The Washington Post even did a story
and they said um that in this type
Market where people won't raise raids
you know wages or
um give them benefits that children are
a good alternative to raising rates and
I swear to God that they did that so we
have to set you don't have to have a
tinfoil hat on to say oh my God they're
actually doing it in Iowa they rolled
back regulations so that 14 year olds
can work in meat packing plants in
logging industry in the construction
industry so like they mean it well and
the other thing too that I think you
point out so well on your social media
is that in this effort because the
children that are going to go work in
the meat packing plants and the lumber
yards or wherever they're working isn't
isn't the rich folks that are going to
get the vouchers it's not it's not the
kids that that that have their parents
money to to go to school where they want
to go to school and then set it home and
not have to work and you know eat bon
bons you know because they always they
always call they always call the the
poor and the and the downtrodden this
country the The Lazy ones like what are
you talking about I have I have never I
have never in my life I have never in my
life met someone like that that was lazy
see you're you're saying the single mom
out there that has three children that
has three jobs that barely has time to
get her kids to school and relies on a
school bus to get them there and I think
that's another point we should go over
you're saying she's the lazy one that
she's the one that doesn't that that
that is that is the one who shouldn't
have that shouldn't have a leg up but um
to that point about the school buses
because I noticed there was a Missouri
rep
and I actually forget his name at this
moment but you go after this no is that
who it was yeah I think so
um they were talking I think you had
said something about how will these kids
get to school and he said well there's
automobiles you know like you piece of
like what in the I mean the idea
that yeah there are automobiles that
exist but that I don't know they cost
money the transportation of a cost money
it takes time to drive in a rural area I
don't know if anyone lives in a rural
area but if you've seen the distance
between school district and School
District in rural areas it's it
sometimes it's 30 minutes to an hour
um from school district to school
district so if your school district
closes Uniontown because of vouchers are
all the parents gonna hop in their cars
maybe they should just maybe you know
Piper maybe they should just um get the
PTA together and have carpools and stuff
you know I mean you know what that the
ptas in these rural areas are really
good at making sure that the schools get
the funding that they need because the
state and the Republican politicians
don't want anything to do with that what
do you think there is no amount of
wrapping paper that you can sell though
and our rural schools but I'll tell you
um going back for one second Betsy DeVos
said this about rule kids she said she
envisioned them having no brick and
mortar schools that they that they
implode all of our schools and that
children like mine listen to eBooks on
headphones while they're you know
working in field so like driving a
combine my 10 year old listening to an
e-book which is really
bizarre and dangerous and stupid so
that's what she thinks of rural people
that we don't even deserve schools but
to your second Point Missouri has not
only passed a voucher scheme but now we
have something called open enrollment
that they're trying to pass and that's
what I was talking about with
Transportation
um because
schools like mine my daughter has 16
kids in the entire fifth grade
um so if people wanted to take their
kids to the nearest town that has you
know like a big sports program a big
Performing Arts Center that would be
Maryville that's 24 miles from me one
way so that's 30 minutes there 30
minutes back and so I asked Tony just
like another person did how are kids
going to get there and he gave you that
smart ass comment well I guess with the
car well listen here Tony there's a lot
of people that work at Kawasaki on the
first shift and they got to be there at
6 30 in the morning how are they going
to get there well hey they're lazy
they're lazy no good doers you know
having that job how dare they have a job
that starts so damn early okay they just
need to get off their butt and go find a
job done start so damn early that way
they can spend money to go transport
their kids I mean here's the contrast
folks because I wanna I don't want to
leave this out the governor of Wisconsin
uh this this week in contrast to Sarah
Huckabee Sanders signing a voucher Bill
and signing to roll back trial labor
laws signed a law to make sure that all
children all children doesn't matter who
you are in a public school if you were
if you go to a public school in the
state of Wisconsin you are going to eat
you are going to eat we are going to
give you breakfast and lunch and it's
not going to cost the parents are the
student a damn dime and and that's the
contrast Democrats Democrats understand
an issue that parents are afraid of and
a lot of parents out there are afraid
that their children aren't going to eat
and and it's not necessarily always
because of money but it's because of the
time that we're talking that that person
on the on the early shift the Kawasaki
not only do they not have time to drive
their kid 30 minutes and 30 minutes back
they don't have time to feed their kid
breakfast in the morning before they
would get on a school bus I mean these
people these are hard-working Americans
it's it's hard to imagine that they
would vote for Republicans a lot of
times they do because the association
because they're not they're not putting
these issues together but there's people
out there that are afraid that their
children aren't going to eat until
lunchtime
um and the and it's not because again
because of money it's because they just
don't have the ability to get them there
and and for the contrast to be the
Democrats want to make sure that
children have nutrition which I I've
always said this I think nutrition
should be the the actual absolute
Foundation of Education like we should
be educating them in the cafeteria about
nutrition about food
um I don't know the contrast there if we
can't if we can't get this National
message out there and push this thing
because Dei is coming Dei is coming
folks it's a new CRT it's the new wokism
Dei is coming and they're going to make
it the demon and they're going to be
talking about it in in
um uh Community meetings and school
board meetings across the country so we
have had the contrast every single one
of your listeners who hear CRT Dei
um social emotional learning uh woke
they need to ask the question to the
person who's saying it what does that
mean and you guys probably all saw that
clip of the lady
um who wrote an entire book on wokism
when pushed by a black reporter to say
say what does that mean she couldn't say
what it means and this is why because
when they say woke they mean black when
they say CRT they mean black history
like that's what they mean so they can't
say it out loud so when you hear it when
your listeners hear it ask them to
Define it what does that mean and where
is it if someone accuses me of teaching
CRT please show me where a lesson
anything let me see what CRT is and they
cannot do that right and another thing
that you said that I think is so
important for missourians to understand
is that we do hear people say all the
time that we vote against our
self-interest and I want to remind
everybody that 40 percent of Missouri
House Seats last cycle went unopposed we
handed our government over to the
Republicans and said here do whatever
you want it's yours we're not even going
to oppose you so 40 That's 2.5 million
missourians had no one to vote for they
did not have a Democrat on their ticket
and that's why I'm so passionate and why
I spend my time traveling the state is
by God people we can't freaking do this
anymore if we're not competing I'll tell
you what happens if we're not competing
and making the Republicans spend money
out in their districts like the
Republicans in my district had to spend
close to 100 Grand they've never had to
spend a dime out here but they knew I
was here and it was possible that I
could win because I raised money if we
do that across the state then we force
them to spend money and when we don't
force them to spend money they head to
St Louis and they head to Kansas City
and Colombia because they've got extra
cash right they're going to start
chipping away at our blue areas so the
longer we keep going and not opposing
these Republicans the quicker our state
gets to read that there's nothing we can
do about it we're in a hole friend right
we don't have any elected Statewide
Democrat not one since um since Nicole
Galloway was gone nothing so I mean we
did get new Democratic you know
leadership we have a new department
chair uh you know a new Co chair I spoke
to Yvonne Reeves last night about you
know the way the the Democratic party is
going to go we got to fund candidates
and we got to make sure there's people
running because we can't do this any
longer
well and I I think you're right it
because if we if we oppose them and have
them competition not only will they have
to spend their money and and actually
work at it but they'll actually have to
get uncrazy uh candidates because they
can have the craziest of the crazy what
do they care there's no competition they
can be the craziest loon on the planet
and it doesn't matter they're going to
vote for them and they're going to win
because they're unopposed and that's
what we have to keep fighting but I
think the most important
um message that we can that we can give
people is that you are the messenger you
are the messenger I know it feels like
you're only one voice and you're only
one vote but it matters it matters if
you speak out it matters if you find
people who are like-minded even if you
don't think they're like-minded but in
that in that Democrats fail sometimes
and liberals fail all the time when they
start saying things like Universal and
you know scary words because these words
I I come from a rural area you come from
rural area these words have scary
meanings and they're they're really hard
to underpin those scary meanings and so
we we have to have a language we have to
do like like um I've said it for a long
time the bill back better bill I wish it
was the big bird bill I wish Democrats
would have said hey this is an education
Bill here's what it's going to do it's
going to make sure all kids get
nutrition all around the country when
they go to public school it's going to
make sure that they start school at
three instead of five and make sure that
parents don't have to pay for that extra
two years of daycare if Democrats would
have been successful with that messaging
there's no way in hell anyone would have
been able to kill that bill in the minds
of Americans but they they used weird
words that scare certain people and I
believe that we these people are on our
side I I know you've knocked a lot of
doors in rural Missouri and there's a
lot of people who think liberal is a bad
word but they are one they are one I
talk to a lot of folks um and we would
have great conversations and they would
agree with everything I said and I've
said this many times but uh they would
end the conversation set you know like
you seem like a nice person
um but I can't vote for you because I'm
a Christian and so we've got a
disconnect a huge disconnect with what's
going on with what they hear at church
what they hear on Fox news right and
then when they see people like me that
they know oh my gosh you taught my
grandson yeah I'm a normal person
um but I have a dimmer so the word
Democrat in rural places is a huge
burden it's a massive burden
um and in fact when I told people I was
running I had so many people say Jess
just run as a Republican and I was like
I can't they like they'll know and
they're like they don't care they don't
look it up they just look at the the
letter behind the name they literally
don't care what you believe it's
Association
um I'm gonna bring in my co-host Gabe
Sanchez because I know he answered a
question for you Jess
um welcome welcome
um did you have a question for Jess here
uh no I didn't have so much a question
as like I just totally uh want to
emphasize what you were talking about
the the
you know you brought up the whole like
Define wokism right and or Define CRT or
Dei or whatever it might be all these
buzzwords that everyone on the on the
right gets super triggered by right
whether it's they don't understand it
and I think it's the boogeyman right
it's the end of of their reign or they
do understand it and they don't want
their
constituents to understand what it is
right the how it would benefit them it
would help educate them and help you
know knowledge sharing is great right
with with knowledge comes power and with
that power comes a greater democracy
but I want to you know I just want to
emphasize what you're talking about
earlier is like we should be questioning
everything they say right when they say
you know we need to lower the age of the
labor laws right to allow it's like you
know it that immediately takes so I'm
from Chicago so it immediately takes me
back to like you know rolling back or
not not even having regulations and
having like bubbly Creek right we're
just having kids tossing oh like just
dead you know carcasses into the river
or into the creek
and just not even thinking about what
the consequences are and we've seen the
the rollbacks and regulations and how
they've affected Us in the last like
three or four weeks with a few different
incidents that have happened uh they're
detrimental effects and they're they're
things that are in place for a reason
right and I think that again you bring
up a good point of we should be we
should be asking him what does that mean
right Define that tell me exactly what
that means so that everyone not only me
but all of your constituents can
understand exactly what you're saying
and I guarantee that most of them will
either trip up and have that same moment
like Bethany Mandel on you know the
rising and we'll be like well it's uh
you know she wrote a whole chapter a
whole book on it yet she can't give you
a 15 second sound bite to be like this
is what it is instead she goes this is
gonna be a viral moment and I'm sure if
we question all of those people even
more there's going to be tons just the
advertisements that they will create on
their own
for us
will be amazing right and so again I
just think that's it is such a great
strategy and it's such a simple strategy
right it's like really is taking the
child approach which is why why and
that's that's what I was gonna say it's
I'm used to doing it because I was a
teacher for so long but if you're
willing to be because it does take
vulnerability to say I don't understand
what you mean by well just like you said
like a young person would I don't
understand what you mean by that word
can you please define it they cannot and
and your audience should know they
cannot Define any of those things and if
they think they can Define it they can't
do it on the spot maybe with a little
Google help they can but if they think
they can Define it they can't find any
instances of it happening so there again
you could say oh okay so I understand
the definition now can you show me an
example of where this has happened in a
school or at a drag show or whatever
they're talking about I mean God forbid
we ask someone to cite their Source
right you're like look if you're gonna
if you're going to uh if you're gonna
wait wait wait they have sources all
right sources I mean if you're gonna do
your own research it's the whole idea
like if you're going to write an essay
and this is your thesis you better have
uh the sources to support your argument
right when someone says well show me an
example and you're like oh well I mean
it's my grandmother's cousin's uh
nephews you know it's like
uh all of these all of these moments
where you would just ask the simple
questions like oh great you have proof
of this I'm sure you have proof of this
and that some anecdote on Facebook of
someone that you know tangentially
through someone at your church and their
kid and that and so on and so forth and
you're like so it's it's just a game of
telephone you don't really know if it
happened and it probably didn't happen
and it's someone it's like someone's
saying they took Ivermectin they cured
covet right like there's no actual
there's no actual proof behind it it's
just someone saying oh well I know for
sure this is a thing and then when you
say okay can you show me proof but this
is this is the war on information right
yes and this is the war that you fight
every single day online and I want to
point this out here here is uh Jess's
Twitter at Piper the number four
Missouri so at Piper number four
Missouri and then our link trees there I
got it highlighted there
um so and and we're gonna put it in the
chat there and I'll put it in the video
description so everyone go go follow
Jess because we we have our favorite
political strategist on our show all the
time Rachel bittickoffer and she is
excellent at messaging and so is Jeff so
you must go follow Jess on all the
social media platforms is there anything
else that I'm missing here Jess is there
anything uh give us a Shameless plug if
you can of of of where they can follow
you because I I believe in your
messaging and I believe you do such a
great job at it yeah so on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook I'm Piper from
Missouri you can find me on Tick Tock
which is one of my favorite mediums that
they want to ban and it's a just Piper
Mo you can find me there I'm also I have
a podcast once a week it's called dirt
road Democrat where I just talk you know
about the things that are important to
us out here and just I want everyone to
know that when you live in a state like
Missouri you can it starts to feel sort
of helpless right and and hopeless and
you are constantly you have your head on
a swivel trying to see what these
god-awful GOP super majority folks are
going to do to an impressed or
marginalized group this week
um but it doesn't have to be hopeless
and when people say move to New York or
move to California no I will not I'm
going to stay right here I got kids and
grandkids here and I've got a farm here
and I'm not leaving and it's just as
much my state as it is theirs over 40
percent of missourians voted for Joe
Biden over 40 percent and now they're
trying to take you know the gerrymander
they're trying to take away our
initiative petition process so that we
can't get things like legalized weed or
you know expanded medicaid they are
doing this so I want everyone to know
even if you're in a place where you're
not you don't have a Democrat on the
ballot start looking now you got a year
and a half to do this maybe someone
listening is the person that can run
right
um we cannot do this any longer so it's
going to take every single one of us but
we can take our state back look at
Michigan look at what they're doing they
they've got a trifecta now and they are
giving away lunches and health care and
and everything and we can do it again
here because we were purple ones and we
can do it again I think you're right and
I think if we if if the pro-democracy
Coalition bands together and uses
democracy to save it instead of using
democracy to destroy it then then we'll
be much better off you you have to come
back again uh the audience is going to
love you I know that for sure our
audience always always loves commentary
like this so please come back again join
us and keep us up to date on the things
that are going uh round and around
everyone check out uh Piper on the
internet uh at Piper for Missouri that's
at Piper for Missouri I think that we're
going to get the link her link tree in
the in the chat here and I'll put the
link in the description below if you're
on a re-watch piper thank you thank you
for joining us I know you had some sick
little ones today and it was hard for
you to get here possibly but I'm so glad
that you were able to make it and
hopefully next week we can have you back
and with some more updates yeah
absolutely I'd love to come back thank
you guys I appreciate it everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break